in this video i'm going to talk a little
bit about points on angle bisectors but
before that i want to at least make sure
we understand what we mean when we talk
about the this the distance between a
point and a line so let's say that that
is some point
point a and this is some line right over
here we'll call that line
line bc so you're taking the distance
between a point and another point it's
very obvious you just you just draw a
line to that other point we'll already
use b you just draw a line to that other
point and you find the length of that
line so distance seems very
straightforward between two points but
what about a point in line because there
are many points on this line so maybe
we're going to find this distance or
maybe we're going to find this distance
or maybe we're going to find this
distance and these are all going to be
different lengths so how do we have one
unique distance and the way that we
think about this and we're going to do
this in much more depth when in in
future math courses especially once you
study vectors and linear algebra and all
the rest is a distance between a point
and a line is really the shortest
distance and that shortest distance is
if you were to drop a perpendicular from
that point to the line so this right
over here
this right over here is what we call the
distance
the distance between the point and the
line and this is perpendicular right
over here and to recognize that this is
indeed the shortest distance think about
this relative to the distance between
this point and then and and and any
other point on this line
so pick another point on this line right
over here let's call this point e
and let's think about this distance now
this is an arbitrary point i could have
drawn e here i could have drawn e here i
could have drawn e anywhere but
regardless of where you draw e if you
draw a line segment between a and e you
see that we form a right triangle from a
to e to the point where we had the
perpendicular so let me call this point
right here f you're always going to draw
a right triangle assuming that e is
different than f and if you do that
you'll immediately see that d has to be
shorter than this orange length because
this orange length is a hypotenuse a
hypotenuse is always going to be the
longest side of a triangle d squared
plus whatever length this squared is
going to be equal to this length squared
so hopefully that at least gives you a
decent sense why dropping the
perpendicular
will always give you the shortest
distance between a point and a line and
that unique shortest distance is what we
call the distance between a point and
line now with that out of the way let's
think a little bit about angle bisectors
so let me draw an angle here
so let me
draw an angle so let's call this point
doing different colors let's call that
point a
let's call this point b
and let's call this point c right over
here and an angle bisector is
essentially a line or segment or ray
that splits an angle into two equal
angles and we've talked about this a
little bit before so for example if we
want to bisect angle abc so this angle
right over here we want to split it in
two
we are going to split it in that i can
actually draw a better version of that
we want to split it into
we want to split it into like let me
draw a little bit better the drawing is
the that still doesn't look like that
looks decent all right and so let's call
this point right over here i don't know
let's call this d and maybe we could
even say that's an array or we could
call that a segment or whatever but the
way to think about this is if now angle
dbc is equal to angle dba
so if this angle
dbc
is equal to angle dba
we can say that db bisects angle abc so
we could say that db
and now i'm talking about segment db we
could have made it array if we made it
keep going to the right or a line
db bisects
bisects
angle a b c
a b c fair enough now the whole reason
why i started this video talking about
distances between points and lines is
that i want to show you that any point
that is on an angle bisector is actually
going to be equidistant from the sides
of the angle and then we're going to go
the other way to show that any point
that is equidistant from the sides of an
angle is going to be on the angle
bisector so let's take an arbitrary
point that sits on this angle bisector
so let's take this point right over here
i'll call that arbitrary point f
or actually i could use e i haven't used
e yet so this is going to be an
arbitrary point on our angle bisector
and now let's look at the distance
between e and bc and the distance
between e and b a we already say that we
already said that the distance between a
point and a line is if you drop a
perpendicular from a point to that line
which you can always do
so let's draw a perpendicular right over
here this is one distance and then this
is the other distance
this is this orange line right here is
the distance between e and b c this is
the distance between and this orange
line is the distance between e and b a
and what i want to prove is that these
distances are equal
well the first thing to realize is that
we have two right triangles over here
they both share they both have this same
angle they're not sharing it but angle a
i should say angle a b e is congruent to
angle c b e and we know that because db
bisects it so this angle is equal to
that angle they're both right triangles
so they actually have two angles in
common which actually means that they
actually have three angles in common it
constrains what this other angle would
be and they also have this side in
common and when i say they have three
angles that are congruent to each other
they're not necessarily in common but it
does have this side in common b e is the
hypotenuse of both of these right
triangles and so you can invoke
using this angle that angle and this
side this angle that angle on this side
you could say that these two triangles
are going to be congruent to each other
so we could say that triangle and let me
put some points over here so let's see
let's call this f and let's call this g
we can say that triangle
e
b
f is congruent to triangle e
b g and we could use the angle angle
side by angle angle side congruency or
you say hey if two angles if two
corresponding angles are same then that
third angle is also going to be the same
so this angle right over here could also
be the same and you could use angle side
angle but either way these two things
are going to be congruent but if these
two things are congruent then the
corresponding sides are going to be
congruent so then
then length of ef
segment ef is going to be congruent to
segment eg which is the same thing as
the length of ef
is equal to the length of eg these are
really these are really equivalent
statements right over there so the
length of ef the length of ef is equal
to the length of eg and the length of
those two segments are the distances
between the point and those two
respective sides so we've just proved
we've just proven the first case if a
point lies on an angle bisector it is
equidistant from the two sides of the
angle
now let's go the other way around
let's say that i have so let me draw
another angle here so let me draw
another angle right over here and let's
call this a
b
and c and let's pick some arbitrary
point e
let's pick some arbitrary point e right
over here and let's say we start off
with the assumption that e is
equidistant to b c and
b a and what we want to do is prove that
e must be on the angle bisector so here
if you're on the angle bisector or
equidistant over here we're going to
show if you're equidistant you're on the
angle bisector so if it's equidistant to
bc and ba then this perpendicular right
over here this perpendicular right over
here is going to be congruent to this
perpendicular
right over there and let me give these
points labels so let's call this point d
and let's call this point right over
here f and let's just draw segment b e
here
let's just draw segment
let's just draw segment b e right over
here so once again we have two right
triangles we already know that two of
the legs are congruent to each other
they both share the hypotenuse this
hypotenuse is equal to itself
we know from the pythagorean theorem if
you know two sides of a right triangle
it determines the third side so and we
know two sides of both of these so their
third sides must be the same
so this side must be equal to that side
so you could invoke sss side side side
to show that these two triangles are
congruent or you actually didn't even
have to go there you could have used a
special case the rsh case where if you
have a right triangle so if you have the
right triangle you have one set of sides
that are congruent and you have the
hypotenuse that is congruent then you're
also k okay you could use rsh to prove
congruency as well and so either way we
know that triangle
e b d triangle e
b d
is congruent to triangle e
it's congruent to triangle e b f we used
side side side here but you could have
used rsh let me write that rsh which is
we know that angle side side can't be
used for any general triangle but it can
be rsh is essentially angle side side
for right triangles if you have two
sides of a right triangle and an angle
and and and if you have two sides of a
right triangle in common then the they
are def if two sides of a right triangle
are congruent then the two triangles are
definitely congruent which is what
essentially this is saying but once you
know that two triangles are congruent
then their corresponding angles have to
be congruent and angle ebd angle ebd
corresponds to angle ebf so we know that
angle e
bd
must be congruent to angle e
b f
so e b d
must be congruent to e b f
well if ebd is congruent to ebf then
that means
that means that segment eb that means
that segment eb must bisect
must bisect
angle
f or i say c b a even it could be called
cbf angle c b a so we're done if over
here we show that if something sits on a
on a bisector is equidistant from the
sides of the angle and here we showed if
it's equal distance from the sides of
the angle it sits on the angle bisector
or
or it could even be the endpoint of an
angle bisector but clearly it sits on it